>> ♪ ♪
>> THE BUSH NAME IS SYNONYMOUS
WITH GOP POLITICS PRODUCING TWO
PRESIDENTS AND THE GOVERNOR OF
FLORIDA.
NOW GEORGE P. BUSH ANNOUNCED
A RUN FOR ATTORNEY GENERAL FROM
THE LONE STAR STATE.
THE MEDIA IS ATTACKING HIS
SUPPORT FOR FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND BLASTING THE CANDIDATE
SAYING HE IS BETRAYING HIS
FAMILY TO APPEASE TRUMP.
GREAT TO YOU HAVE HERE, GEORGE.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
>> I AM A BIG SUPPORTER OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I HEARD FROM PEOPLE KNOWING YOU
WOULDOB THIS EVENING TO ASK YOU
HOW YOU CAN CONVINCE -- WE
APPRECIATED YOUR SUPPORT OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
PEOPLE HEAR THE NAME BUSH AND
HAVE A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
OPINIONS AND FEELINGS
EMOTIONALLY AND POLITICALLY.
SOMETIMES WE AGREE TO DISAGREE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS WATCHING THIS
PROGRAM, THAT YOU ARE DIFFERENT.
YOU ARE NOT A TROJAN HORSE.
YOU ARE NOT SAYING WHAT NEEDS TO
BE SAID AT THE TIME WHICH
POLITICIANS DO TO CURRY FAVOR?
HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN YOURSELF
BEING A BUSH AND A UNIQUE ONE IN
THE MIDDLE OF TODAY'S POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT.
>> WELL, TAMMY, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME.
IT'S THE SAME RESPONSE WHEN I
FIRST RAN FOR OFFICE IN 2014.
IT'S MY NAME ON THE BALLOT.
I AM MY OWN MAN.
I WILL BE ON THE PHONE AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND TAKE THE
CALL LATE AT NIGHT WITH A BORDER
PATROL OFFICIAL OR A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL FALLS IN
THE LINE OF DUTY.
THERE ARE FOUR SO FAR IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT MY RECORD AND
MY SUPPORT OF TRUMP, I STICK TO
THE FACTS.
THE FACT IS IN 2016 I WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST STATEWIDE ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO SUPPORT HIM.
I RAISED A MILLION AND A HALF IN
SUPPORT OF REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES
UPON TEMPERATURES A HIGH WATER
MARK FOR REPUBLICAN PARTY
POLITICS IN TEXAS.
IN 2020 I DECLARED THAT TRUMP
WAS THE ONLY THING STANDING
BETWEEN OUR COUNTRY AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SOCIALISM.
I TURNED OUT TO BE CORRECT WITH
OVER 30 TRILLION DOLLARS IN
SPENDING AND 6 TRILLION DOLLARS
IN NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT MY POLICIES, I
AM ALL ABOUT AMERICA FIRST.
TRUMP IS THE CENTER OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
I AM MY OWN MAN.
I SUPPORT HIM.
WE NEED TO CARRY ON THAT LEGACY
AND CAPTURE THE LIGHTNING HE
BROUGHT TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> THROUGH THE HOLIDAY SEASON,
YOU ARE THE SON OF JEB BUSH, THE
CONVERSATIONS MUST BE
FASCINATING.
YOU ARE STRONG AND DISTINCT IN
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE PRESIDENT.
MANY MEMBERS OF YOUR FAMILY DO
NOT LIKE HIM.
DO YOU HAVEN'T THOSE
CONVERSATIONS?
HOW DO YOU HANDLE THAT?
>> WELL, WE ARE JUST LIKE ANY
AMERICAN FAMILY.
WE HAVE OUR DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION.
WHETHER IT'S WITH RESPECT TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR WITH RESPECT
TO HOT BUTTON ISSUES OF THE DAY.
I HAVE MY OWN VISION, PLAN AND
TRACK RECORD HERE IN TEXAS.
I WON OVER A FEW SOULS BECAUSE
OF THE FIRST 150 DAYS OF THE
BIDEN/HARRIS ADMINISTRATION.
I THINK I WILL WIN OVER MORE
HEARTS AND SOULS.
>> AND HOPEFULLY WILL HAVE THE
LAST NAME OF BUSH.
WE NEED YOUR FAMILY TO
UNDERSTAND THE POWER OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND WHAT CAN
HAPPEN TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THIS ELECTION IN 2022 FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL RUNNING AGAINST
THE CURRENT ATTORNEY GENERAL
PAXTON.
YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE DOING THAT?
YOU THINK YOU HAVE THE SUPPORT
FOR THAT?
>> I DO.
I THINK TEXANS DESERVE TO HAVE
A CHOICE.
IN 1976 REAGAN RAN AGAINST AN
INCUMBENT PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE
FELT CONSERVATIVES SHOULD HAVE
A CHOICE AND IN TEXAS THEY
SHOULD HAVE THA